I mean does this feel good emotional
it's the ending of such a huge chapter
but so great to see the movie recognize
it feels all of those things it feels
like an exciting and exciting ending and
as we know because we've been working on
it the last few years and exciting
beginning but the fact that that the
world responded the way and marks
beautiful intro to us pointing that out
really means a lot and I we said goodbye
to some characters but we think we did
in the most important ways which is with
the respect and honor and when the whole
lot of feeling and and we left a lot of
Tears lassitude still crying to spend
all this time together how much is
everybody staying in touch just as the
family that you are you should see our
text thread we miss you when we getting
back together where should we meet
I gotta ask what's next face the next
phase well what can we expect we've
announced a lot of it we're into it as
we speak once in post one's shooting two
others start next week it's it's gonna
be an amazing future mark more of you
how much more can we get I don't know
probably more I do tasks you guys I mean
irishman also getting acknowledged
tonight and enemas award season begins
how do you feel about how things
ultimately played out with what Martin
Scorsese had to say about the movies
it's their new art form it's something
different from films that are shown
normally in theaters that's all there is
there's a great amount of respect that
we have for him as a filmmaker and we
work really hard to make movies for
everyone and we will work even harder
maybe someday he'll like what we do well
said well said I'm you know I worked
with Marty I love Marty I hope he gets
to see the film one day because so many
of us as filmmakers have have really
actually stolen from him
and learned so much from them and I
think if he sees it he'll see what a
kind of homage it is to to the cinema
that he's created in the past I'd like
to see Avengers up there at the Oscars
guys I mean let's make yes I'm ready
yeah from your mouth to God's ears
what would you love for Hulk to do in
the future I'd like to see him hang out
with some of the new folks you know
maybe maybe maybe be like a guru to some
of the new the younger ones yeah it's a
good idea spider-man's back right back
yeah y'all feeling good arts he never
left no he's still with us
[Music]